alors le modem suis donc la ligne fixée
par son patron françois bayrou pas
d'accord national mais des alliances au
coup par coup avec la gauche ou la
droite on vient de le voir à pau où il
est pourtant au coeur d'une triangulaire
délicate françois bayrou a refusé la
main tendue de l'ump sur place emilie
keno loïc le moigne même à table il se
dispose-t-on triangle débat animé ce
matin au journal sud-ouest et sourire un
peu crispé de françois bayrou
la partie s'annonce difficile pour le
président du modem qui arbore toujours
uniquement les couleurs de son parti il
a refusé toutes les offres de soutien de
l'ump
je ne participe à aucune tractation ya
des maires de villes importantes de
droite et de gauche des candidats de
villes importantes qui ont appelé j'ai
parlé avec eux mais je vais pas m pour
balance avec tout d'abord parce que si
je le faisais plus personne n'aurait
confiance en moi et pourtant un soutien
aurait sans doute arrangé les affaires
du président du modem sérieusement
menacé par sa rivale socialiste martine
lignières cassou peut-être enthousiaste
elle est arrivée en tête dimanche
dernier et observons maintenant d'un
oeil extérieur les stratégies de son
concurrent
je pense que la stratégie qui consiste à
dire comme le dit ici françois bayrou ni
gauche ni droite ni même modem en ce qui
concerne sa liste
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
déboussolent sa boussole
yves urieta lui ne l'a pas perdu un seul
cas pour le maire sortant maintenir sa
liste coûte que coûte ils croient qu'ils
ont gagné les autres maisons tort ancien
socialiste soutenue par l'ump yves
urieta n'a récolté au premier tour que
28% des voix
beaucoup auraient voulu le voir se
retirer sans succès
allez à bientôt
ils y apprennent étiquette ump il n'ya
pas d'étiquette centriste a ni de gauche
nous sommes une liste rassemblant des
femmes et des hommes qui ont envie de
servir la ville alors qu'il pleut sans
discontinuer sur pau depuis deux jours
le ciel politique lui semble s'éclaircir
aujourd'hui à les choses sont posées
trois listes quatre jours pour
convaincre avec un handicap
supplémentaire pour françois bayrou qui
part avec quelques 400 voix de retard
sur sa rivale socialiste